we're told to list an order from
smallest to largest so each of these
quantities it looks like we have
expressions inside of absolute value
signs and just as a bit of review
absolute value just means your distance
from zero or another way to think about
it is if you're it's a negative number
inside of the absolute value sign it
becomes positive if it's already
positive it stays positive so let's
think about these numbers so the first
one is the absolute value of five the
absolute value of five how far is five
away from zero well it's five away from
zero so it's equal to five so if I were
to actually draw a number line you would
see that zero is here five is over here
this distance right there is five so the
absolute value five is five
now the next quantity they want to do
what they want us to figure out is the
absolute value absolute value of nine
minus seven
well this is the same thing as the
absolute value of two nine minus seven
is two and once again two is just two
units away from zero so it's just two if
you have a positive value in the
absolute value sign it just is itself
the absolute value of 2 is 2 then we
have the absolute value of 5 minus 15
absolute value of 5 minus 15 well that's
going to be the same thing as the
absolute value 5 minus 15 is negative 10
so it's the same thing as the absolute
value of negative 10 now there's two
ways you can think about it if it's a
negative number inside of the absolute
value sign it just becomes the positive
version of it so it just becomes 10
another way to think about it is if you
had negative 10 you would plot it it
would be out here someplace negative 10
we'd have to extend the number line it
is 10 to the left of 0 that's what the
absolute value is telling us then we
have the absolute value of 0 we have the
absolute value of 0 well 0 is just 0
away from the number line absolute value
of 0 is just 0 that is just 0 that's
just right there it is has no distance
from the origin and then finally we have
the absolute value of negative 3
absolute value of negative 3 that's 3 to
the left of
or you can just think of it as getting
rid of this negative sign so it is equal
to three so now that we've expressed
them all is just simple integers let's
list them in order from smallest to
largest so of all of these values which
is the smallest this one is the smallest
the absolute value of zero so let me
write that down
absolute value of zero what's the next
smallest what's the next month since we
have a two there this is the next
smallest right there and that original
expression was the absolute value of 9
minus seven so the absolute value of
nine minus seven and then what's the
next smallest so we have this three and
then we have a five and a ten so the
next smallest is this three right here
that three and that original expression
was the absolute value of negative three
absolute value of negative three then we
have this five over here which was just
the absolute value of five and then
finally we have this ten over here which
was the absolute value of five minus 15
five minus 15 and we are done